we came here at the start and it was a
10 foot by 10 foot block of snow those
20 feet tall this is 25 tons of snow the
first day we moved about two tons of it
the first step is to kind of shave off
any excess from the corners and then we
start to rough out from the top down the
head where the arms are gonna be and you
can see behind me that it's come quite a
long way since it's been B square we are
more of the freeform variety where we
knew kind of what the Bears were
supposed to be cut the corners shave the
head we've got various mounted tools
like ice auger for ice fishing we use
that to create some of the negative
space you see in between the Bears we
use about a 30-foot long piece of barbed
wire with handles on either end here's
one of our special tools it's a handmade
saw we have some old military trench
shovels too they all have razor-sharp
edges the shovels are more rough cut
stuff gets rid of huge blocks of snow at
once kind of give you a forum but at
this point it's too dangerous to hit it
hard because it's softer and we don't
want to lose an arm wet the weather
really problem after some it's a it's
the biggest problem this wall we left
standing because we're so exposed to the
Sun the wall started out a foot thick
and now it's less than half of that all
that Sun would have that would have been
our piece eroding when it's slushy
really hard to get a nice clean sharp
edge when the snow is nice and cold you
nee can sand it with sandpaper and
polish it like marble
can we hope that they denied the trust
makes the sculpture a little bit harder
Germany down there always does an
amazing job they pull off gravity
defying feats if the snow is strong it
has a lot of power if you can make
really crazy things here we have
sistersong and it's if it's too cold you
have another problems it's easier as we
go because now is fine-tuned finer
detail working it into product it is
hard but it's a good kind of hard what's
really fun about it is working on the
monumental scale to get a chance to work
in something 12 feet tall with people
from all around the world such a gas you
know people come through and they're
amazed at what we've been doing if they
take away that at the smallest fashion
line that was cool then I'm happy
you